-Le revirement de
beaucoup de spécialistes..
..sur ce qu'on appelle
le langage des cités.
On s'est souvent extasiés,
il y a 10 ans,
..sur ce mélange de verlan
et de mots inventés.
Aujourd'hui, il est considéré
comme un handicap,
..voir un facteur d'exclusion,
..notamment au moment
de la recherche d'un emploi.
[Commentaire en verlan.]
[Propos en verlan.]
...
-Vous n'avez..
..rien compris
à leur conversation ?
C'est normal.
-On a parlé d'une fille.
On a dit le mot "pain".
-"Frais", ça veut dire "beau".
-"Guizgui", c'est un problème.
-Ces lycéens ont grandi
à Ivry.
Leur langage,
..c'est leur façon..
..de se reconnaître.
Ils en ont même fait
un clip.
...
Les mots différent
d'une banlieue à l'autre :
..pour une fille,
on dit "rapin" ou "darzouse".
Natacha Polony,
ex-prof de lettre en banlieue,
..a arrêté et milite
contre ce langage des cités.
-Vous disiez que..
..la langue française..
..a beaucoup de mots.
-Il y a plusieurs mots
qui sont synonymes,
..mais ça dépend...
-"Je suis affamé", c'est plus
fort que "je veux manger".
-On dit "j'ai aimf".
-"J'ai la dalle".
-Qu'on dit "j'ai faim"
ou "je suis affamé,
..c'est pareil.
-Selon des linguistes, certains
jeunes ne possèdent que 400 mots,
..contre 2 500 pour..
..leurs enseignants.
D'où, pour N. Polony,
..l'importance du langage.
-Pourquoi un employeur..
..accepterait d'avoir
en face de lui un salarié..
..qui ne saura pas..
..capable de discerner..
..certaines nuances dans
les ordres qui sont données,
..ou capable de rendre compte..
..d'une mission qu'on
lui a demandé de remplir ?
-L'académicien Erik Orsenna est
moins radical. Il trouve même..
..aux dialogues de "L'esquive",
une certaine poésie.
-Elle est belle ?
-Elle est "fracassante",
stylée...
-"Fracassante"...
Dire d'une robe
qu'elle est belle, c'est plat.
-Pour lui,
le "parler jeune"..
..peut enrichir,
mais il pose des conditions.
-La langue est..
..notre contrat social,
..notre pacte social,
notre lien social le premier.
En France, on doit
parler la même langue.
Mais qu'il y ait des gens
qui inventent,
..qui réveillent...
J'aime cet exemple
d'avoir la haine.
On peut dire "je déteste",
.."je n'aime pas"...
Rien n'est plus fort
que "avoir la haine".
-Cédric, Franck..
..et leurs copains d'Evry,
..élaborent un lexique.
Vous apprendrez qu'être..
.."Alcatraz",
..c'est d'être privé de sortie.
Une boîte de six,
..c'est un faucon de police,
référence aux beignets de poulets...